it's not enough
JoJo siwa struts with Raven Simone and
it's cheetahlicious
[Music]
I love it so much JoJo joins Raven and
her wife Miranda Mayday for a dance
party on Tick Tock the song of choice
the cheater Girls 2 classic struck
you'll remember the iconic moment in the
2006 Disney Channel movie filmed in
Barcelona
[Music]
and seems Raven AKA Galleria still has
the song Down pack
[Music]
the message of the Cheetah Girl Movement
is the most beautiful thing I think I've
ever been a part of and the stories that
can come out and have come out have
shaped and molded
many generations which is awesome
the big question now I'm waiting for the
real cheetah cheddar with my girls
will the Cheetah Girls ever reunite for
a movie reboot
[Music]
I need to talk to the girls first
because we need to we need to curate an
answer
this can go so sideways and so many
levels listen I'm done with Adrian
whatever Adrian's done do I'm down yeah
Raven gate E.T this glimmer of hope a
few years ago I love everybody in their
own ways you know what I'm saying but if
we could get the four of you in a room
is there a plot relevant today for the
cheetah I would love to be a part of
that brand again but it needs to be
genuine you know what I mean you we all
have to be there
um and you know it was my bad for not
being in the fourth one
that was my bad but uh you know who
knows hey after Corona Anything is
Possible in the meantime we've got JoJo
Raven and Miranda giving us all the
cheetah Nostalgia we need
and it's not enough
[Music]
foreign